Navarro's dream cabinet for potential
second term run Navarro hardcore Trump
loyalist gives axios an exclusive look
at the passage containing potential
choices for second term cabinet form his
uh forthcoming book taking Trump back
taking back Trump's America some old
gang choices for 2025. former Trump
National Security adviser Robert O'Brien
for Secretary of State Ben Carson to HHS
Bob uh light instead of instead of the
urban yeah
yeah which was like come on give me a
break here by the way if Carson had been
there when the pandemic hit we would
have been a lot better off go ahead I I
I think a lot of people agree Bob uh
light uh light tezer lighthizer
lighthizer to Commerce a cash Patel to
Director of National Intelligence John
Radcliffe the CIA director
Ken kuchellini returning as head of
Homeland Security oh he went over the
DeSantis card so I gotta rethink that
but go ahead Dan uh bro it in second
term of energy Linda McMahon tuhad yeah
David Barnhart in second term of
interior and for New Blood with strong
Trump loyal tiles judge Jean Janine
Pirro Fox News attorney general some say
she may not have a job for too long with
Tom her and uh uh uh what's her name
Uma yep that's the name of that spin but
go ahead okay former Congressman Sean
Duffy to Head transportation love him
Bill Gertz for dni or CIA Oracle CEO
Safra uh uh Katz or Lara Trump as U.N
Ambassador and Mike Pillsbury Frank
Gaffney and Brian Kennedy as ambassador
to China nails so any other names you
would say
um that and by the way it this is this
is for the cabinet right now for him to
win West Wing right for fright enough
for him to win 2024 do you think he has
the right people on his team today to
win 2024. uh yeah so far yeah but but
but it's early in the campaign and
there's a lot of Demands on President
Trump now one of the things that really
worries me is he's got this think tank
it's not his but it's they're using his
name to raise a bunch of money it's run
by
um Brooke Rollins who uh was a good
friend of Ivanka and ran uh the domestic
policy Council in the final months
and
half of the people are more at that
think tank or never trumpers and
documentingly so it's like what what the
hell's going on there's just a lot of
people measuring the drapes now on the
outside and um you know I'm my counsel
to the bus over and over is going to be
you know your most important decisions
will be Personnel initially and we can't
we can't let history repeat itself there
what what would you say were you know
you always here if you work for
president Trump loyalties at the top
right it's very important to be loyal to
him what other things you think he
values to get people on the inside well
he doesn't suffer fools gladly I mean
look if if you got to have you gotta
have the smarts and the Loyalty that's
that's the combo
um
and um he's a very
some of the great greatest times I had
in the Oval Office
um were were when we were debating
complex policy issues are in the
Roosevelt room
um with
group groups of top advisors where he'd
go around the room and listen and you
know if if if somebody started saying
something that
that wasn't smart he'd cut them off or
if you know he is an eerie way of
finishing your thought you can see kind
of he moves things along but um
in 2016 after he won there wasn't a lot
of developed Talent at that point
because nobody thought he was going to
be able to run and there was some some
problems we had early
uh that paved the way for uh
um rhinos to get into positions of power
I mean I I like rides now and by the
time reince got fired he was on the
Trump train but when he first came in
um
he he wanted no part no part of anything
related to getting tough on trade he was
a strict Paul Ryan Wisconsin Republican
they just wanted to pass a tax bill and
repeal Obamacare they talked the boss
into that and it was a it was a disaster
because they couldn't deliver the vote
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]